ومن العراق سالنا ما هو القرار الوظيفي
الذي ستتخدونه للعام القادم
[موسيقى]
طبعا انا ما احب غير اييي عملي من صغري
وانا على هذه المصلحه نفسها
اليوم صعبه تيجي بعد هذا العمر كله تيجي
تغير مصلحتك غير مصلحه ما تقدر لان انت
تعودت وفتحت عينك على هاي المصلحه حاليا
وظيفه حلوه بصراحه
الاعلام خصوصا في التخصص العلاقات العامه
شيء حلو ومرتب اللي تكون علاقاتك مع ادت
شخصيات من الفنانين او مسؤولين او هالامور
فانا افضل يعني بصراحه كل انسان
[موسيقى]
الحقيقه انا متقاعد حاليا متقاعد لكنه
العمل موجود والعمل ما ينتهي بالنسبه الي
شخصيا لان انا عندي اهتمام عبد الحقيقه
اهتمامات ادبيه قراءه وكتابه الشغل
صار لي لمده اربع سنوات او تقريبا من بعد
الاعداديه
حتى بالجامعه انه انا اشتغل على انه يكون
المصور
شغلي واغير اختصاصي